today we're talking about how halo
infinite's mangler could be getting
nerfed horizon forbidden west leaking
early and more
let's go ahead and kick this off with
some halo news one of halo infinite's
new weapons the mangler might be getting
a nerf in the future while no other
official changes have been announced 343
industries recently stated it was aware
of feedback regarding the weapon and the
discussions are happening internally the
news comes via halo esports and
viewership lead tashi who recently
responded on twitter to halo pro snipe
down's suggestion that the weapon needs
to be on a longer spawn cycle other pros
began to chime in asking for a better
flow of communication between players
and 343 in regards to balance changes
and feedback tashi stated that 343 has
definitely been seeing all the feedback
and talking about it internally
especially for big ones like the mangler
and stated to those in the thread that
official feedback surveys were on the
way so we can capture it all in a clear
and concise way unquote it's currently
unclear if 343 industries would nerf the
weapon's damage ammo pull respawn times
or all or none of the above but even 343
simply stating that talks about the
weapon are happening internally has more
casual halo fans worried on the game's
subreddit many players are begging 343
to keep the gun as is and not cater to
pro players when it comes to balancing
halo infinite players point to the fact
that 343 nerfed the commando rifle and
the ravager following halo infinite's
technical previews resulting in the two
weapons largely not being worth picking
up currently that's something fans don't
want to happen to the mangler too others
point out that if other lesser used
weapons received buffs then perhaps some
angler wouldn't be a go-to weapon for
more competitive players this comes
right alongside complaints from xbox
players who have reported instances of
cheating by pc players as a result
they've been continuously asking for the
option to toggle off crossplay so those
on xbox can more easily avoid pc players
343 industries has acknowledged the
prevalence of cheaters early on saying
that due to halo infinite's to play
nature it will unfortunately always have
cheaters however the studio is actively
looking for ways to combat them as 343
announced that it will be releasing an
update in february to address the
cheating issues
switching gears to horizon forbidden
west because it might be time to mute a
couple keywords on twitter an unfinished
build of horizon forbidden west has
leaked online ahead of the game's
upcoming launch on february 18th images
claiming to be from a ps4 version of the
game began appearing online this week
and according to vgc's sources the
content is genuine the build that leaked
is mostly complete and aside from some
missing art assets it features all the
content currently planned for the game's
final release sony has been quick to
pounce on any leaks so far similar to
2020 situation with the last of us part
2 and has issued takedown notices on any
images that have begun circulating on
twitter leaked gameplay hasn't appeared
on sites such as youtube yet although
it's likely that sony will move fast to
scrub that content from the video
sharing site or other file sharing sites
hosting the leaked content the easiest
way to avoid horizon spoilers is to only
watch gamespot content of course you can
thank us later
in other playstation news the platform's
top downloaded games for december 2021
have been revealed and across north
american and european regions among us
has taken the crown for the most
downloaded among us made its console
debut in december and at a four dollar
price point the popular social game was
an easy purchase for fans and newcomers
alike while players were trying to
figure out just who the most such person
was around them the rest of the top 10
featured newer games such as call of
duty vanguard madden nfl 22 and
battlefield 2042 in the us and canadian
charts while the european list had a
similar spread of games in its top 10
list
with that said what new games did you
download in december and how are you
liking them so far let me know in the
comments and leave a like subscribe and
of course we will see you tomorrow for
some more gamespot news
[Music]